33 heures après l'enlèvement du baron
empain c'est toujours l'incertitude la
famille n'a reçu aucun message des
ravisseurs
on ignore s'il s'agit de l'enlèvement
politique ou d'un acte de banditisme
dans la 604 du baron empain retrouvé
hier soir dans un parking de la porte
champerret il y avait bien une serviette
en cuir et plusieurs trousseaux de clés
mais ces objets n'ont pas permis de
faire progresser l'enquêté
il appartenait au baron empain les
policiers ont alors cherché à arrêter
les ravisseurs dans les mailles d'un
gigantesque dispositif de contrôles
organisés sur la région parisienne
cent quarante mille véhicules et deux
cent quarante mille personnes ont ainsi
été contrôlés en vain
reste les coups de téléphone anonymes
diverses et contradictoires reçue par
plusieurs organes de presse
doit-il vraiment être prise au sérieux
le groupe d'extrême gauche n'a pas
démenti ce soir dans un communiqué être
à l'origine du rapt la police néanmoins
ne néglige aucune piste
la police n'exclut dans cette affaire
aucune hypothèse et procède bien
évidemment à toutes les vérifications
à l'heure où je vous parle c'est à dire
à 18 heures il n'a pas été possible
d'authentifier ces coups de téléphone
est ce que vous pensez franchement que
le n'a pas fait une organisation
suffisamment structurée pour se livrer
un tel rapt je vous répète que tant que
la police n'a pas d'éléments lui
permettant d'avoir des certitudes
elle envisage toutes les hypothèses
question les éléments concrets ce soir
en dehors de ces coups de téléphone il
n'y a pas d'autres éléments concrets
donc à l'heure où je vous parle toutes
les hypothèses restent encore possibles
[Musique]